it's great to be joined today by Kent
Greenfield who's professor of law at
Boston College in an expert in
constitutional and business law ken it's
so great to talk to you and I want to
talk a little bit about the role of
business in Donald Trump's America and
this is a particular interest right now
we recently have been following this see
I guess I could call it a conflict
between Donald Trump and some of his
administration and the retailer
nordstrom which has decided as they say
not for political reasons but merely as
a business decision to no longer carry
Ivanka Trump's clothing line and this
has created some very very interesting
dynamics between a White House and
presumably a business that is free to
make the business decisions that it sees
as best for it there's quite a lot more
to this dynamic as you've been talking
about isn't there that's right a
Norseman is a great example to start
with but I think there's a bunch of
other examples too i think the
Nordstrom's example is interesting
because Nordstrom's seems to be about
making a business decision but it's been
called out by the President of the
United States for treating his daughter
unfairly that that seems to an
unprecedented and be hard to imagine any
other president doing doing such a thing
but I think northland situation speaks
to a larger problem that many many
businesses are now facing what do you do
when when the president focuses on you
and we've seen that with with mortems
we've seen that with with a Boeing we've
seen that with a few other companies it
on the other hand some of them some of
some of the sorry some of the probe
business pro Trump business activities
on one of the major shoulders of LL
Bean's go got in favor of Trump and a
bunch of progressives have started a
boycott ll being campaign so I think
what what interests me and all of this
is what do businesses do
ooh in Trump's America both if your
progressive or if you're not so and what
should we expect them to do in this kind
of in this kind of a political moment
that we find ourselves in my analyses of
the various protests rallies and marches
that we've seen since the November a
selection of Donald Trump I've said I've
praised and criticized the marches when
I felt that they deserved one or the
other but one of the broader messages
I've had is that actually uh in addition
to whatever types of protest rallies
Marge's etc people want to participate
in progressives made at may actually be
able to impact the Trump administration
particularly through some of the friends
and cronies of Trump and his team
through their actions related to
businesses and this is you know sort of
the obvious one could be the boycotting
of Trump businesses but I've actually
said I think more effective than that
would actually be protesting at Trump's
businesses because it's very likely that
there aren't that many progressives who
are customers but they could actually
send send quite a message and get a lot
of attention by protesting Trump's
businesses but you wrote to me that you
actually see a business and corporations
as a way in which progressives may be
able to have influence over what's going
on in the country can you expand on that
a little bit and tell me sort of what
you meant yeah so let me step back for a
moment and talk some about what one of
the Bugaboos for progresses over the
last seven years now has been the
Citizens United decision which which
which was a Supreme Court decision that
said that corporations could engage in
politics as if they were human beings
and so it's uh it's the most famous
corporations or people opinion that
people have criticized and in part
rightly so in a weird way I think
citizens united was one of the but for
causes of Crump's election because it
highlighted the dis association and the
distance between the corporate elites
and the managerial and financial elites
and average Americans and I think the
Democratic Party
for for many years has been trending
toward paying more attention to Wall
Street and the financial league and less
attention to the working class Americans
around us and and I think so that dis
Association helped pave the way for the
anger that brought about the context
that made it possible for Trump to win
now having said that now that Trump is
in office ironically citizen unite will
I'd be thankful that to the United lose
their in this respect citizen citizens
united was based on the notion that
corporations have something to say in
the political world cooperation of you
know there and there are exceptions on
both sides i'm talking broadly but
corporations don't want to get in this
mess they don't want to be identified
with Trump their their messages have to
be more diverse have to be more
culturally attentive they have to look
more the long-term they have to be more
more global and so the the my point i
think is that when you look at like the
coca-cola commercial during the Super
Bowl where America the Beautiful is
being sung in a diverse array of
languages when you see the new Amazon
commercial where you have the priest and
a mom buying each other on knee pads
these are the kinds of things that are
that are an important element of
corporate speech that that that will
tend to counterbalance the tribal
insularity of the Trump world that we
are starting to see is that a lot of a
concern there in the sense that I mean
of course what you're saying makes sense
which is hey you know what here's one
way in which citizens united may
actually allow some of these messages to
be heard from corporations but
systemically or structurally I don't
think that that should necessarily
impact our broader view about
uncontrolled amount of money in our
political system should I mean I guess
what you're saying is you're finding a
silver line
so to speak I am a man I completely
agree and here's and i agree with you
David that the problem is money in
politics where I differ somewhat with
with with the conventional progressive
story about this is that it's not
particularly corporate money then we
have to be worried about it i mean i
should sheldon adelson and the Koch
brothers individually spend much more
money than for-profit publicly traded
corporations do and so the so the worry
is money and politics aren't necessarily
corporate money in politics so so I
think that we need to fix the problem of
money in politics but I think focusing
on corporate personhood is is a
distraction now the one thing that I
want to make sure that I talked about
and are a few moments together I think
one of the ways to improve to address
the problem of corporate power and
corporate power even in politics is to
focus on the way we govern corporations
and i don't mean political money have
what i mean is how we govern and and
regulate corporation from the corporate
law perspective and so one of the things
that I do i do business law and i do
corporate law and this is an area where
i think a progressive view on the
business loss i can help us address some
of defects that we've seen in the
constitutional side and livi well can
you give us some examples i mean i know
yeah why don't you wrote the book the
failure of corporate law where you
address at least some of these issues
i'm sure our audience would be
interested in hearing some of the
specifics that you would have in mind so
so yes thanks i I think the more
democratically governed a corporation is
the less I worry about the corporation
be involved an immigrant and democracy
so for example in Europe is some it's
very common for corporations to have
employees on the borders of directors in
Germany you know companies like BMW
mercedes-benz demons they all have half
of their Board of Directors being
elected by the employee of the company
so they have fewer days lost or strike
they've got a higher worker productivity
and the companies themselves it
themselves have see themselves having a
broader so
contract that can't be encapsulated by
just the bottom line return to
shareholders and that's something that
we could change we could change as a
matter of business law in corporate law
here in eternity in the united states
and i will say that we could change at
the state level so we don't have to wait
for a republican-dominated Congress to
make these changes we can simply do that
state-by-state at the state level now
there are some complications there
obviously but my main point is that I
think progresses ought to expand their
attention not focus just on on
constitutional doctrine and overturning
Suzy knighted as a matter of
constitutional law but we could we
should expand our our pallet of options
to include changes in business law and
if we changed business law and
progressive ways we could worry less or
we would need to worry less about the
defects that we've that we've seen over
the last few years in constitutional law
and in money and politics in terms of
some of the specifics that the average
individual can participate in with
regard to their relationship to
businesses in the Trump era what advice
do you have I mean what what can the
individual do with regard to their
buying choices when it comes to products
and services well i think i agree with
you right that that our buying choices
we all not only act as citizens when we
go into the polling booth but we also
act as citizens when we go into the to
our local supermarket when we go into
our local variety store or a local big
box store and i think that matters
secondly i think many of us because of
our ownership and pension funds or may
have some money in the stock market here
and there we are also act as citizens
and when we act as shareholders and one
of the things we're going we're
increasingly seeing is that shareholders
operating together whether in pension
funds or even individually can can
assert their power as shareholders in
companies asking companies requiring
companies to disclose their political
contributions for example to disclose
their their efforts on climate change
and I
once we see ourselves as human beings
that operate as citizens and all these
different aspects of our lives that's
where we can start to really assert our
powerhouse as progressive I'll remind
you we've been speaking with boston
college professor kent greenfield check
out his book the myth of choice personal
responsibility in a world of limits as
well as the other book I mentioned the
failure of corporate law Cranton Kent so
great to speak to you today thank you do